- Three minutes of
feedback can change
your business if you
think about it smartly.
I don't wanna hear
this, "I don't have time".
As the boss, you have time.
Go fuckin' execute.
("Unstoppable" by This Is Wolff)
("No Greater Love"
by JMKM X 32KEYS)
- [Nate] Have you ever
done the "talk to text" stuff?
- It's really good right?
- [Nate] Yeah,
it is really good.
- Okay, I'm open to it,
especially with headphones now.
Teach me.
- [Nate] You just click,--
- Oh, this you mean?
- [Nate] No, no, no.
- Oh, this thing, right?
- [Nate] Yeah, and
it's actually really solid.
- Yeah, it is.
- Wait, lemme
practice something real quick.
It really is, right?
How was your birthday, Claude?
- It was so good.
- Did you guys see the video
that Claude got for my kids?
- No.
(Claude groans)
- It's good shit.
("No Greater Love"
by JMKM X 32KEYS)
- We need some
help in prioritizing
who gets to move, so
as far as at the end of-
- Who gets what, right?
- [Claude] Yeah.
- Great.
- [Claude] Gabe, Das,
it's just all coming in now.
- Makes sense.
I have an idea.
- [Skye] Yeah?
- Can you change
this whole section
to have more
seats than it has now?
So it can become the new preview
to how many
seats I think we should
actually have in this company?
- [Claude] Double up?
- I know we
talked about that before,
you mean like, just adding--
- Can you blow this side out?
- [Skye] Like,
take out the desks?
- Stick with me.
Let me play a game
with you real quick, ready?
Right now, this seats,
two, four, six, eight, right?
- Yes.
- I want it to seat 12, and
then blow the whole thing out.
Done.
We have to do it anyway, because
that's what's gonna happen.
- How are you
gonna fit 12 desks here?
- No not 12 desks.
- They're gonna share.
- Well, look what's going on.
- You would have
people share a desk?
- No, there's way
too much room here.
There's just like
way too much room here.
This is all gonna be my
kind of characters anyway,
so they're not gonna
be all bent out of shape.
- So--
- I mean, there's six fuckin'
people in a hell of
a lot less space there,
than there is 12 here.
- Their desks are the same
width as each of these desks.
48 inches is the
width of all these desks.
- Great.
Make anybody
associated directly with me
get comfortable with 36 inches.
Fuckin' squeeze
everybody, Danny David?
How many inches does he have?
- I don't know.
- 48 inches.
- [Gary] How many
inches do you need
of desk space, Danny David?
How much?
- [Danny David] 16.
- [Gary] 16, my man.
- [Skye] You need
more than 16 inches there.
- [Danny David]
16 is my last offer.
- No no, he's getting 16.
And then we'll
figure out the rest.
So here's what I
want you to do ASAP, ASAP.
Get rid of this
and standing desk it,
I wanna see how
many I can actually fit,
cause I have a
funny feeling I can do
maybe three rows
of it, like there's
some stuff
running through my mind.
- Upstanding?
- Get me a proper
standing desk situation here.
Alright Skye, you
ready for the tweets?
- Yes.
- Good green shirt by the way.
- Thanks (laughs).
- Alright, we're
putting standing desks,
we're doing a
standing desk situation,
if you're a standing
desk creator or manufacturer,
I don't know what
the hell the word is,
hit up Skye,
we're looking for deals.
You'll be in DailyVee.
- Yes, good deals.
- Good deals,
we like good deals.
("Eleven:11" by Pell)
If you're a manager,
a leader, a CEO,
a C-suite, if
you're running shit,
three minutes can make
an impact on your business.
I hope you
caught that whole thing.
Run it.
From the
beginning, to right now.
Listen, I wanted to
grab you for three minutes,
literally 100
seconds, to tell you
that you are
absolutely crushing it.
- [Man] Thanks, bro.
- And the feedback
is all the way through.
- [Man] Awesome.
- And you're
really putting yourself
in a position to be
very successful here.
- [Man] Awesome.
- I think you're capturing "it",
and I'm gonna push us there,
and you should keep
following your instincts
and hustle and energy
and I'm just impressed.
- [Man] Dude, greatly
appreciate it, man.
- That's it, man.
My inbox is open,
keep doing your thing,
but I need you to
have that in your pocket.
- [Man] Sweet, I appreciate it.
- My pleasure, my man.
Have a great day.
- Always appreciate the time.
- No worries man, no worries.
- Take it easy.
Have a good one.
- You, too.
- [Taylor] Hi, how are you?
- Taylor, how are you?
- How's it goin'?
- Good, how are you?
- I'm good.
- What's cookin'?
- [Taylor] Not much.
- Life is good?
- It's been crazy,
moving to New York was insane.
- It's a big ass deal.
- But yeah, I love it here.
- Listen, I'm sure
you're probably wondering
why I'm calling you in.
- [Taylor] Yeah.
- I'm calling you in
for a very good reason.
- Okay.
- You're doing
exceptionally well.
- Okay, thank you.
- And very much
look the part of what
I'm trying to build around here,
and I wanted you
to know that from me.
- [Taylor] Oh, thank you.
- Yeah.
- [Taylor] That's so nice.
- I'm really happy
with your work.
I think the company
is seeing it at the
highest levels, and I think
you're really putting
yourself in a great position
and I really just want
to take this one minute
to A, give you a good day,
and I'm sure it's fun to hear,
but B, for you to also know
that you have direct access
to me if there's
anything I can be a help of.
Any ideas you have,
any thoughts you have,
any needs you have, I really
want you to use me as an asset,
and I'm just really
impressed with your work.
- [Gary] Oh, thank you!
That means so
much, that's so nice.
- Follow your instincts on this.
Like, just keep
doing what you're doing.
Don't overthink this meeting,
just keep doing
what you're doing.
- [Taylor] Yeah, totally.
- Alright?
- [Taylor] Cool.
- That's it.
Well that's nice to
know I can reach out to you.
- Yeah.
- [Taylor] They always say
that, but you never know.
- People don't believe it.
- [Taylor] Yeah.
- So I keep trying to
hack it, so whether it's
negative reinforcement,
positive reinforcement,
winking at people,
grabbing them at
parties and saying hello,
or the most fun,
something like this and saying,
hey, not only is
this good feedback,
this is really good
feedback, and worth me taking
some of my time out to
tell you that to your face,
you should take
advantage of that, okay?
- [Taylor] Totally.
- Cool.
- [Taylor] Thank you.
- That's it.
- [Taylor] Well, I have to go
get back to Sonic (laughs).
- I get it, I got
things to go to as well.
Keep up the good work.
- [Taylor] Thanks so much.
- Yeah, I mean it.
- [Taylor] Appreciate it.
- Three minutes of feedback
can change your business
if you think about it smartly.
I don't wanna hear
this, "I don't have time".
As the boss, you have time.
Go fuckin' execute.
- Cool, you're ready to go.
- Hey guys, it's me.
Really starting to step
up on my podcast and give you
some context and
pretext to some of these talks.
This is a talk
I gave the other day
to an incubator
around logistics,
a bunch of startup founders
in Chattanooga, Tennessee.
Ted and his team there
had Dynamo and Lightpost,
real great partners,
friends, just people I enjoy
down in Chattanooga, and
they've got this incubator
around logistics companies
and I just kind of gave in
and shot my shit and
the energy of the room
and the moment in time,
I think created a really good
piece of content and
so I know you're running
on the treadmill
right now or walking the dog
or driving into work, so
I know that you're passively
consuming this at times,
so for everybody who kind of
passively consumes,
pay triple attention.
This one's deep.
This has some shit.
You agree, right?
- Totally.
- This is some shit.
Listen to some shit.
Enjoy this episode.
- Alright, man.
- Thanks a lot.
- How you enjoying it so far?
- Love it.
- It's good?
- For real,
yeah, I really love it.
- Cool, man.
Looking forward to sitting down
and getting to know you better.
- You, too.
- See you soon.
("Queso" by Pell)
- [Gary] What's up man?
I knew I'd get to see you,
I wasn't planning
on being here today.
- [Seth] I was telling him you
weren't supposed to be here.
How you doin', bud?
- Good to see you.
- [Seth] Good, good.
- Feel free to
call in a favor or two.
- [Seth] It's funny,
I was telling AJ I created this
podcast, Sports with Friends
it maintains
relationships, you know?
- [Gary] It's important.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] I highly recommend it.
- Alright brother.
- [Gary] Good to see you
brother, talk to you soon.
Tyler!
("Late Flip" by JMKM)
Have you been able
to gather any intel yet?
I know that we kind of
moved quickly for this.
Like literally, I want
to set up a call or two.
I just want to talk
about some framework.
Yo, hey everybody real
quick, just wanna talk,
Schutz is in the house.
- Sup y'all?
- Running the four D's
program, he stole it from Nate,
Nate takes it very personally,
they have a huge rivalry,
but just wanted to
get on Instagram live
as we're kind of wrapping up.
Basically, I've only
been promoting this through
Instagram live,
so many of you guys
know about the four D's,
Daily Digital Deep Dive, the
one day consulting product
that VaynerMedia
sells that has been going.
Steve, why don't you give
them, how many have we done?
- [Steve] We've done
three sessions so far.
- [Gary] The media strategy
thing has been big, right?
- Unbelievable.
- [Gary] So, honestly, as a lot
of you guys know, the biggest
thing that I've been stunned
about is people who follow me,
look, if you're spending
$10,000 for the product
and flying to New York,
you're like into my thesis,
this has only been
done through Instagram live,
like some of you in
here right now, by the way,
if you've gone to a four D,
and you're in here right now,
make that known and
give the honest feedback.
Don't listen to
bullshit Schutz-man here.
But the media
thing has been real.
The Claude thing,
the media thing, the culture
and the media thing have
been the "things", right?
- [Steve] And content strategy,
understanding how
do you come up with,
how do you understand
what your North Star is
or what your
unifying message is,
and then how do you come up
with a strategy that allows you
to create a piece of content
that's for the right platform,
what platform should you be on,
how do you know
where your target is
or where your
leads are coming from.
- We are picking the
final dates of four D's
that I'm guaranteed to be in,
so as we start promoting this
as VaynerMedia, we're not
gonna make the guarantee of me,
and so just kind of
giving one last about,
so Nate, what's the punch line?
- [Nate] May 25th is
open, June 8th is open,
you're guaranteed
at both of those,
and we have some dates in
July, we'll open more in June,
though I can't
guarantee you in those.
- [Gary] Alright,
so one more time.
- May 25th, June 8th for sure.
- Alright, guys.
- [Jon] You're a pretty
good-lookin' guy, don't worry.
- [Gary] So, if you look down
here, four D's at VaynerMedia
if you want to be part of
one of the first six or seven
inaugural events,
four D's is a full day here
at VaynerMedia, New York City,
10 hours consulting session.
Now we're putting people
in a private Facebook group
as well, that's
been interesting.
- [Steve] Yep, tons of
conversation going on there.
The community has been
leveraging each other after
the day to talk through other
challenges, business problems,
celebrate each others'
successes, stay in touch,
a couple of deals are
being done, so it's been great.
- May 25th, June 8th,
get to New York City,
one hour with me with the group,
and so hope you guys
enjoy it and join it
and I'll talk to you soon.
("Late Flip" by JMKM)
What's up guys, 3:56 P.M.,
me and DRock
heading to the airport
and trying to make this flight,
we might be late again,
but we're not going to,
as you can see,
I'm on my iPhone,
we're not going to be filming,
so we can get the episode
for you tomorrow because
we got an overnight flight
to the U.K.,
excited about our trip,
and excited about today.
Got a lot done in
a very short window.
Happy Birthday, Mom.
I love you very very very much,
and that's most important today,
and that's the scoop.
Alright, this is me
stealing DRock's job
as we're walking through.
Anyway, welcome to the airport,
hustlin', about to do a
new intro to the DailyVee,
workin' on that,
little eight-second
little dingy,
that's that.
Heathrow, here I come.
("Late Flip" by JMKM)